[Music]
facebook says it is developing the next
step in the future of communication only
on CBS this morning we are getting
behind-the-scenes look at the social
media Giants new virtual reality
platform that creates lifelike replicas
of real people doing that with their
mouths but it involves the mass
collection of data and Facebook still
faces criticism for scandals surrounding
how it handles the personal information
of its more than one and a half billion
daily users DeMarco Morgan got a first
look at the technology at a lab in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania expression to
create an avatar that looks moves and
sounds like you 180 cameras in 500
lights capture your face that's cool you
are from different angles puff out your
cheeks making all sorts of silly faces
you are doing fantastic 180 cameras
cameras high resolution high framers so
why so many so the reason is because we
want to be able to understand exactly
how you look from every different
viewpoint because in virtual reality
we might move and look at you from
different perspectives and it has to
look as real as you do yeah so Shake
directs the Facebook reality lab in
Pittsburgh creating these avatars it's
an evolution from the telephone to video
conferencing and this could be the next
sort of way of actually spending time
with a friend you haven't met in 10
years you can both sort of say let's
meet at the Eiffel Tower and suddenly
you materialize there oh wow when you
put the goggles on you see a
three-dimensional version of the person
you were talking to you so it feels like
they are right in front of you oh this
looks real to make it real the scanner
captures 180 gigabytes of data per
second that's less than 2 seconds to
fill a typical laptop hard drive a lot
of data to give a social media platform
like Facebook we didn't take a broad
enough view of our responsibility and
that was a big mistake which is still
reeling from a series of massive data
scandals last year including the
improper collection of 87 million users
data by a political consulting firm 50
million accounts compromised by hackers
and reporter deals made by Facebook to
share intrusive access to user data with
more than 150 different companies
including Netflix and Amazon which
Facebook denies it's impossible not to
ask the question is there a dark side to
this Peter Rubin is a senior
correspondent in Wired who covers
virtual and augmented reality it
collects a lot of data about us and
increasingly about the way that we look
in the way that we behave in the way we
react to things it feels much more
invasive than just having our web
surfing monitored but Facebook says
security is a top priority any concerns
about hackers of course something which
I consider to be the existential threat
to this kind of technology if we are not
mindful of this and develop safeguards
in the system itself it really threatens
the viability of this entire medium of
communication for CBS this morning
tomorrow Morgan Pittsburgh